Hola. De hecho, eso es "hola" en Bauer Bodoni
para los apasionados por la tipografía entre nosotros.
Uno de los argumentos que parece llegar
fuerte y claro en el último par de días
es la necesidad de reconciliar lo que el Grande quiere --
el "Grande" siendo la organización, el sistema, el país --
y lo que el "Pequeño" quiere -- el individual, la persona.
¿Cómo podemos unir ambas cosas?
Charlie Ledbetter, ayer, yo pienso, habló muy articuladamente
sobre está necesidad de incluir consumidores, traer gente
al proceso de creación de cosas.
Y de eso es de lo que les quiero hablar hoy.
Entonces, traer y unir El Pequeño para ayudar a facilitar y crear El Grande.
Yo creo que es algo en lo que creamos - algo en lo que yo creo
y algo a lo que más o menos damos vida
a través de lo que hacemos en Ideo.
Yo llamo a este primer capítulo -- para los Británicos en la sala --
El Destello Cegador de lo Extremadamente Obvio.
Comúnmente, las buenas ideas están mirándote tan fijamente a la cara
que como que se te escapan. Y yo creo, que muchas veces,
lo que hacemos es, en cierto modo, levantar el espejo a nuestros clientes y decir:
"¡Obvio! Mire lo que realmente está sucediendo."
Y en lugar de hablar sobre ello en teoría,
creo que que mejor les enseño un ejemplo.
Una empresa grande de asistencia médica de Minnesota nos pidió
que les describiéramos cual era la experiencia de sus pacientes.
Y yo creo que estaban esperando --
ya habían trabajado con muchos asesores antes --
yo creo que esperaban algún tipo de organigrama horrendo
con miles de burbujas y sistemáticos estos, aquellos, otros más,
y todo tipo de diagramas.
O aún peor, algún tipo de espantosa muerte-por-Powerpoint
con diagramas "Wow" y todo tipo de, ustedes saben, Dios sabe, cosas.
La primer cosa que compartimos con ellos fue esto.
Lo voy a poner hasta que sus ojos se disuelvan.
Esto es 59 segundos entrados en el vídeo.
Al minuto y 59.
Tres minutos 19.
Creo que algo pasa. Creo que una cabeza aparece en un segundo.
Cinco minutos con diez.
Cinco minutos 58.
Seis minutos 20.
Les mostramos todo el vídeo
y todos estaban preguntándose: ¿qué es esto?
El punto es que cuando se está acostado en una cama de hospital todo el día
y todo lo que se hace es mirar el techo, la experiencia es realmente mala.
Y sólo hay que ponerse en la posición del paciente.
Él es Christian, trabaja con nosotros en Ideo.
Simplemente se recostó en la cama de hospital
y, más o menos, sólo miro el techo de poliestireno
por mucho tiempo.
Así es como es ser un paciente en un hospital.
Y su reacción fue como, ustedes saben: destello cegador de lo extremadamente obvio.
Válgame Dios. Por lo tanto, viendo la situación
desde el punto de vista de la persona hacia afuera --
en contraste con la perspectiva tradicional de la organización hacia adentro --
fue, para ellos, una revelación.
Y así, esto realmente fue un catalizador para ellos.
Así que entraron en acción.
Dijeron, bien, no es sobre cambio sistemático.
No es sobre gigantescas, ridículas cosas que se tienen que hacer.
Es sobre las pequeñas cosas que pueden hacer una diferencia gigantesca.
Así que comenzamos a crear prototipos de algunas pequeñas acciones
que pudiéramos hacer para tener un gran impacto.
Lo primero que hicimos fue que tomamos un pequeño espejo de bicicleta
y lo pegamos aquí, en una camilla, en una silla de ruedas
para que cuando te paseaba una enfermera o un doctor
pudieras, en efecto, tener una conversación con ellos.
Podías, en cierta manera, verlos en tu espejo retrovisor,
aso que creo una pequeña interacción humana.
Un ejemplo muy pequeño de algo que podían hacer.
De modo interesante, las enfermeras mismas entraron en acción --
dijeron, bien, adoptamos esto. ¿Qué podemos hacer?
Lo primero que hicieron fue decorar el techo.
Lo que creí que era realmente -- Le mostré esto a mi madre recientemente.
Y creo que mi madre ahora cree que soy algún tipo de decorador de interiores.
Así es como me gano la vida, un poco como Laurence Llewelyn-Bowen.
No particularmente la mejor solución de diseño del mundo
para aquellos de nosotros que somos apasionados diseñadores de profesión.
Sin embargo, una solución fabuloso y empática para la gente.
Cosas que empezaron a hacer ellos mismos --
como cambiar el piso entrando al cuarto del paciente
para que significara: "Este es mi cuarte. Este es mi espacio personal." --
fue una solución de diseño muy interesante para este problema.
Así que se va del espacio público al privado.
Otra idea -- que me encanta -- que vino de una de las enfermeras
fue que tomaron pizarras blancas tradicionales
y las pusieron en una de las paredes del paciente
con esta etiqueta adhesiva.
Así lo que se puede hacer es entrar en el cuarto
y escribir mensajes en la pared a la persona que estaba enferma en esa habitación.
Eso es encantador.
Así pequeñas, diminutas soluciones tuvieron un impacto enorme.
Yo creo que ese fue un muy buen ejemplo.
Esta no es una idea particularmente nueva:
en cierta manera, ver oportunidades en las cosas que están a tu alrededor
y tomarlas y convertirlas en una solución.
La historia de la invención está basada en esto.
Voy a leer esto porque quiero decir bien los nombres.
Joan Ganz Cooney vió a su hija -- bajó un sábado por la mañana
vió a su hija viendo la carta de prueba
esperando a que programas comenzaran una mañana
y de eso resultó Plaza Sésamo.
Malcolm McLean se estaba mudando de un país a otro
y se preguntaba por qué le tomaba tanto tiempo a estos chicos
subir las cajas al barco.
Él inventó el contenedor marítimo.
George de Mestral -- estos no son bichos sobre una sandalia --
estaba caminando a su perro en un campo y quedó cubierto de abrojo,
pequeñas cosas espinosas, y de eso salió el Velcro.
Y finalmente, para los británicos, Percy Shaw -- este es un gran invento británico --
vió los ojos de un gato al lado de la carretera
mientras regresaba a casa una noche y de ahí salió el catafaros.
Ahí está toda una serie de ejemplos sólo apoyándose de los ojos,
viendo cosas por primera vez, viendo las cosas de nuevo
y usándolas como una oportunidad para crear nuevas posibilidades.
La segunda, sin sonar demasiado zen,
y esta es una cita de el Buda:
"Encontrándote en los margenes, viendo a las orillas de las cosas
es a menudo un lugar muy interesante para empezar."
Una visión estrecha tiende a producir, yo creo, soluciones restringidas.
Así es que, mirando abiertamente, usando la visión periférica,
es un interesante lugar para buscar oportunidades.
Otro ejemplo médico.
Nos pidió un fabricante de dispositivos --
nosotros hicimos la Palm Pilot y la Treo.
Hicimos mucha tecnología sexy en Ideo --
ellos habían visto esto y querían una pieza sexy de tecnología
para diagnostico médico.
Este era un dispositivo que usa una enfermera
cuando están haciendo un procedimiento de la columna vertebral en un hospital.
Le piden a las enfermeras que capturen datos.
Y tenían esta visión de la enfermera, de cierta manera, haciendo clic
en un dispositivo de aluminio
y todo esto siendo increíblemente moderno y lujoso.
Cuando fuimos a observar este procedimiento --
y voy a explicar esto en un segundo --
fue muy obvio que había una dimensión humana en esto
que ellos no estaban reconociendo.
Cuando están insertando una aguja de 12 centímetros en tu columna --
el procedimiento del que el dispositivo en cuestión debía capturar datos --
era para ayudar a controlar el dolor. Estás asustado -- perdiendo el control.
Así es que lo primero que cada enfermera hacía
era sostener la mano del paciente para brindarles confort. Este gesto humano
hacia que la fabulosa manera de capturar datos con dos manos que se quería fuera completamente imposible.
Así resultó que el dispositivo que diseñamos, mucho menos sexy
pero mucho más humano y práctico, fue este.
No es una Palm Pilot aunque se esfuerce la imaginación,
pero se puede navegar con el pulgar para que se pueda hacer todo con una mano.
Así es que, volviendo a esto -- la idea de un pequeño gesto humano
dirigió el diseño de este producto.
Y yo creo que esto es realmente muy importante.
De nuevo está aquí la idea de tener una solución alternativa.
Usamos esta frase, "solución alternativa" mucho,
más o menos, mirando a nuestro alrededor. De hecho viendo a mi alrededor aquí en TED
y viendo todo este tipo de cosas suceder
mientras estoy aquí.
Esta idea de la manera en que la gente junta soluciones en la vida
y el tipo de cosas que hacemos en nuestro ambiente
que son algo subconscientes pero tienen tremendo potencial -
eso es algo que buscamos arduamente.
Escribimos un libro recientemente, quizá lo recibieron
llamado "¿Actos Irreflexivos?"
Ha sido todo sobre este tipo de cosas irreflexivas que hace la gente
que tienen gran intención y gran oportunidad.
¿Por qué seguimos la línea en la calle?
Es una imagen en un metro en Japón.
La gente inconscientemente sigue cosas aunque, ¿por qué?, no lo sabemos.
¿Por qué alineamos el empaque cuadrado de lecho con la cerca cuadrada?
Porque tenemos que - simplemente estamos obligados a hacerlo.
No sabemos por qué, pero lo hacemos.
¿Por qué pasamos el cordón de la bolsa de te alrededor del asa?
De nuevo, estamos usando el mundo a nuestro alrededor
para crear nuestras propias soluciones de diseño.
Y siempre le decimos a nuestros clientes: "Deberías mirar esto.
Estas cosas son importantes. Esto es lo realmente vital."
Esta es gente diseñando sus propias experiencias.
Puedes conseguir algo de esto.
Asumimos que si hay un poste en la calle
está bien usarlo. Así que estacionamos nuestro carro de compras ahí.
Está ahí para nuestro uso, en cierta manera.
Así que, de nuevo, nos apropiamos de nuestro ambiente
para hacer todas estas cosas distintas.
Nos apropiamos de otras experiencias --
tomamos un artículo y lo transformamos en otro.
Y este es mi favorito. Mi madre me decía
"Sólo porque tu hermana brinque en el lago no significa que tú debas hacer lo mismo"
Pero todos lo hacemos. Todos nos seguimos los unos a los otro todos los días.
Así es que alguien supone
que porque alguien haya hecho algo
eso los deja a ellos hacer la misma cosa.
Y es como si hubiera este señalamiento alrededor de nosotros todo el tiempo.
Quiero decir, bolsa plástica significa "parquímetro descompuesto".
Y todos, más o menos, sabemos leer estas señales.
Todos nos comunicamos en esta manera altamente visual
sin darnos cuenta de lo que hacemos.
La tercer parte es ésta idea de no saber.
De ponerse a si mismo al revés conscientemente.
Estoy hablando sobre siempre estar des-pensando las cosas.
Como tener una mente de principiante, dejando la mente limpia
y viendo las cosas de nuevo.
Un amigo mío era diseñador en IKEA
y su jefe le pidió
que le ayudara a diseñar un sistema de almacenamiento a ser usado por niños.
Este es el librero "Billy" - es el producto de mejor venta en IKEA.
Ármalo. Martillalo con un zapato si eres como yo
porque son imposibles de armar.
Pero es un librero muy popular. ¿Cómo repetimos esto pero para niños?
La realidad es que cuando miras a los niños,
ellos no piensan en almacenar cosas en términos lineales.
Los niños asumen permiso de manera muy distinta.
Ellos viven sobre cosas. Viven debajo de cosas.
Viven alrededor de cosas
así que la relación con su consciencia espacial
y su manera de pensar en almacenaje es completamente distinta.
Así es que lo primero que tienes que hacer -- este es Graham, el diseñador --
es, de cierta manera, ponerte en sus zapatos. Y así, aquí lo tienen
sentado debajo de la mesa.
Entonces, ¿qué resultó de esto?
Este es el sistema de almacenaje que diseñó.
¿Que es esto? escucho que todos se preguntan. No, yo no.
(Risas)
Es esto, y yo creo que es una solución particularmente linda.
Así es, como saben, es una manera completamente distinta de abordar la situación.
Es una solución completamente empática --
fuera del hecho de que el peluche probablemente no se la está pasando muy bien.
(Risas)
Pero es una manera muy simpática de cambiar la perspectiva a lo ordinario
y este es un buen ejemplo.
De uno mismo ponerse en la posición de la persona
y yo creo que es uno de los temas que escucho de nuevo
en esta conferencia es: ¿cómo nos metemos
en los zapatos de otras personas y realmente sentir lo que ellos sienten?
¿Y cómo usar esa información para crear soluciones?
Y yo creo que eso es de lo que se trata esto.
Última parte: el brazalete verde. Todos tenemos uno,
de esto se trata.
Quiero decir, es sobre escoger batallas suficientemente grandes que importen
pero suficientemente pequeñas para ganar.
Y de nuevo, ese es uno de los temas
que creo se ha dicho alto y claro en esta conferencia:
¿Dónde empezamos? ¿Cómo empezamos? ¿Qué hacemos para empezar?
Entonces, de nuevo, se nos pidió diseñar una bomba de agua
para una empresa llamada ApproTEC en Kenia.
Ahora se llaman KickStart.
Y de nuevo, como diseñadores
queríamos hacer este aparato increíblemente hermoso
y gastar mucho tiempo pensando en la forma.
Y eso era completamente irrelevante.
Cuando te pones en el lugar de esta gente
cosas como el hecho de que el aparato este de debe poder doblar
y cargar en una bicicleta son mucho más relevantes
que la forma que tiene. La manera en que se produce:
tiene que ser hecho con métodos indígenas de manufactura
y materiales indígenas.
Así es que tenía que ser visto completamente desde el punto de vista del usuario.
Nos teníamos que trasladar completamente a su mundo.
Así es que lo que parece un producto torpe y tosco
es, de hecho, increíblemente útil.
Está propulsado así como una escaladora -- bombeas hacia arriba y hacia abajo.
Niños lo pueden usar. Adultos lo pueden usar. Todos lo usan.
Está cambiando a esta gente -- de nuevo uno de los temas --
los está cambiando a emprendedores.
Esta gente lo están usando de manera muy exitosa.
Y para nosotros, ha sido grandioso
porque nos ha ganado montones de reconocimientos de diseño.
Así es que logramos reconciliar las necesidades de la empresa de diseño
con las necesidades de los individuos en la empresa
-- sentirse bien sobre un producto que estaban diseñando --
y las necesidades de los individuos para los cuales estábamos diseñando.
Ahí lo tienen bombeando agua a 9 metros.
Como un gesto final, repartimos estos brazaletes
a todos ustedes esta mañana.
Hemos realizado una donación de parte de todos los aquí presentes
a KickStart, sin doble sentido, a su siguiente proyecto.
Porque, de nuevo, yo creo que hay que poner nuestro dinero donde están nuestras palabras.
Creemos que este es un gesto importante.
Así que hemos repartido brazaletes. Lo pequeño es el nuevo grande.
Espero que todos los usen.
Eso es todo, muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)